bonjour et bienvenue sur France 24
bienvenue ici à New York nous sommes en
marge de l'Assemblée générale des
Nations Unies et notre invité
aujourd'hui le nouveau président du
Kenya William Routot merci beaucoup
il s'agit évidemment de votre premier
assemblée générale des Nations unies ça
me fait que 10 jours que vous avez pris
vos fonctions présidentielles il y a
désormais un enjeu majeur qui est la
sécheresse qui frappe votre pays la
Somalie et l'Éthiopie la pierre
sécheresse depuis 40 ans sans doute en
tout cas mais la tension du monde elle
est tournée ailleurs
j'en ai parlé à l'Assemblée Générale
rien qu'au Kenya il y a plus de 3,1
millions de personnes qui sont touchées
par la sécheresse
[Musique]
le véritable coupable c'est le
changement climatique
là on parle d'autre chose évidemment à
cause de la guerre en Ukraine mais je
crois que le très grand danger le très
grand danger beaucoup plus de gens sont
affectés
[Musique]
parce que au Kenya il a fallu se
réorganiser
à cause de cette famine
c'est quelque chose qu'on devrait pas
traiter comme une situation d'urgence
parce que
c'est devenu
la norme
ça fait quatre ans qu'on affronte cette
situation la cinquième année on sait pas
ce qui va se passer donc ce sont des
choses pour lesquelles il faut se
préparer ce sera pas une urgence c'est
devenu un danger plus permanent
au bailleur de fonds internationaux
d'apporter une aide au niveau de la
dette pour votre pays mais pour d'autres
pays africains ce à cause de la pandémie
de la crise alimentaire et énergétique
qu'est-ce que vous demandez exactement
déjà travaillé avec différents pays
pour annuler une partie de leur dette
alors ce que je demande c'est qu'on
comprenne mieux ce qui se passe pour nos
économies parce que avec la pandémie
on a désormais des prix alimentaires qui
sont très élevés un coup de la vie qui
est très élevé la guerre Ukraine
complètement bouleversé la dynamique de
l'approvisionnement des céréales et des
engrais
et puis
il y a cette sécheresse donc vraiment la
situation est très grave
sont les économies qui ne peuvent pas
répondre à cet ensemble de défis
et c'est pour ça que c'est important
parce que beaucoup pays dans le Kenya
doivent réorganiser leur budget il faut
même réduire les crédits de l'éducation
les crédits de la santé les crédits de
l'eau pour pouvoir répondre à ces défis
posées par la famille et tout ça à cause
du changement climatique
combien est-ce qu'il vous faut monsieur
le Président oui allô
il s'agit d'environ 80 milliards de
shillingénians à court terme
86.5 milliards pour être précis et sur
le long terme pratiquement 4 à 500
milliards de shilling kenyang
si vous considère l'ensemble de la Corne
d'Afrique
des filles encore plus grands se posent
ailleurs c'est pour ça que je dis que ce
n'est plus une un défi que chaque pays
peut relever il s'agit d'un défi qui est
multiple multilatéral et c'est pourquoi
les institutions les bailleurs de fonds
le G20 le Conseil de sécurité
doivent s'atteler à ce chantier très
grave
monsieur le Président j'aimerais revenir
sur certaines crises régionales il y a
de nouveau la guerre dans la région du
Tigré on Éthiopie il y a également
l'Érythrée qui est impliquée quelle est
votre niveau de préoccupation avec cette
situation il semblerait que les choses
tournent mal nous sommes très préoccupés
très préoccupés parce que
ce qui se passe en Éthiopie va forcément
avoir de répercussions sur le Kenya nous
sommes les deux plus grandes et
économies de cette région
et par conséquent
il est important d'intervenir
[Musique]
que lorsque j'ai pris mes fonctions j'ai
demandé à mon prédécesseur de poursuivre
les efforts
le processus qui a été entamé
pour qu'on puisse trouver une solution
de ce conflit en Éthiopie depuis
j'ai parlé
avec le président ramafosa
avec le Premier ministre
habitation
et hier j'ai une conversation avec le
secrétaire d'État monsieur blinken il
s'agissait de voir quels sont les cadres
les mécanismes qu'on peut mettre en
place pour répondre
à ce défi qui se pose en Éthiopie
dans le dans un cadre défini par l'Union
africaine avec le soutien du président
bassanjo avec le plus soutien du
président kenyata dans l'ensemble des
autres dirigeants on devrait pouvoir
amener
l'ensemble des acteurs à la table de
négociation le plus rarement rapidement
possible parce que cette guerre
nous coûte beaucoup
et elle risque de
mettre en danger l'ensemble de la corde
d'Afrique
et la mettre dans une situation très
grave et nous avons parlé du Président
kenyata on a pu être très surpris que
vous ayez nommé comment envoyer en
Éthiopie et en République démocratique
du Congo étant donné votre historique
pourquoi l'avez-vous fait parce que je
suis différent
je suis convaincu
le président kinata peut apporter une
contribution à ce processus en Éthiopie
et en RDC
quelque chose entre lui et moi c'était
de la concurrence
entre lui et moi mais une concurrence
entre lui et la personne qui soutenait
nous sommes une démocratie nous avons
suffisamment de maturité pour comprendre
que on peut être concurrent mais on n'a
pas besoin d'être ennemis on peut être
concurrent et rester compatriote et
c'est pour cela que je crois parce que
je considère que le président kenyata a
une contribution apportée à ce processus
il devrait continuer de contribuer à ce
processus et apporter son leadership
ça c'est du passé je suis désormais
Président c'est moi qui suis responsable
et si tout s'écroule c'est moi qui
serait responsable
et moi je veux le meilleur qu'il y ait
pour la région
je veux apporter au kenyan ce dont ils
ont besoin et je ne peux pas le faire si
la région n'est pas avec nous
ce sont des problématiques régionales
qui doivent être résolues pour que je
puisse me concentrer sur le Kenya et sur
les problèmes du Kenya qui doivent être
résolus
puisque nous parlons des problématiques
régionales le Kenya s'est impliqué
directement en Somalie
[Musique]
depuis 15 ans maintenant il n'y a pas
d'horizon pour le retrait des troupes un
Chabab continue de menacer aujourd'hui
vous êtes Président si vous recommande
est-ce que vous pouvez dire au kenyan
une date de retrait des troupes ou
est-ce que vous dites que les troupes
resteront aussi longtemps qu'il le
faudra
dès qu'elles auront rempli leur mission
ça fait 15 ans monsieur le Président
cela fait 15 ans je me rends compte nous
avons travaillé avec de nombreux
partenaires
mais désormais je crois que les
perspectives sont meilleures avec
l'élection du président Hassan je l'ai
rencontré deux fois
il a une idée beaucoup plus claire de la
direction qu'il faut emprunter et je
crois qu'il est plus engagé à combattre
alchabab
je crois que c'est beaucoup plus clair
pour nous qui sommes impliqués nous
avons travaillé avec de nombreux
partenaires nous continuons de
travailler avec les États-Unis par
exemple qui sont intervenus en Somalie
de manière à pouvoir stabiliser le pays
une Somalie sans stabilité
ne peut qu'être dangereuse pour
tous parce que c'est la porte ouverte au
terrorisme à l'instabilité et cela
affecte le Kenya donc pas de date
définitive pour le retrait des troupes
ça hier mais ça ne résout pas le
problème
c'est pas tellement pour la Somalie
c'est beaucoup plus pour le Kenya pour
ma dernière question j'aimerais revenir
sur un élément récent
après votre prise de fonction récente
vous avez tweeté que le Kenya n'allait
plus reconnaître la République Arabe
démocratique
par la suite été supprimé le ministre
Affaires étrangères a dit que ce n'était
pas le cas j'aimerais simplement
clarifier la situation est-ce qu'il
s'agissait d'une erreur ou est-ce que la
position du Kenya évolue vis-à-vis de
cette situation qui évidemment très
sensible pour le Maroc et pour toute la
région la position du Kenya
a toujours été et continuera d'être la
position des Nations Unies
le Maroc et l'ensemble de la région
doit être traitée de manière
démocratique
notre position
c'est la même que celle des Nations
Unies et nous n'avons pas modifié donc
le tweet était c'est la même que celle
des Nations Unies donc rien n'a changé
rien n'a changé je souhaite vous
remercier pour votre présence ici sur
France 24 ne vous interviews peu après
votre prise de fonction à la présidence
du Kenya merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette édition ici sur France 24 depuis
New York
chaque semaine retrouvez l'Afrique dans
toute sa diversité et sa richesse avec
des reportages de nos correspondants sur
le terrain et des interviews de
personnalités phares africaines dont
vous propose un décryptage de tout ce
qui fait l'actualité sur le continent
société économiste sport et culture on
vous parle des grandes tendances de
projets novateurs et de parcours
exceptionnels je vous donne rendez-vous
pour Africable sur France 24 et France
24 point com